Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie
Netflix just released the live action
one piece series.
the adapted the entire east blue saga
from the beginning of the manga.
Or if you only watched
the animated series,
It was about the first 61 episodes
of the anime, which itself includes
some stuff
that wasn't in the original manga.
way they ended things made it seem that
they're pretty confident
that they're going to get a season two.
So we'll break it all down
and whether or not they were able
to break the curse of the live action
anime adaptation, which Netflix
has had issues with in the past.
if you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
I will do videos for one season two
and like the next big live action.
Not necessarily anime, but anime adjacent.
Avatar The Last Airbender series
will be airing on Netflix next year.
I've already done
a trailer video for that.
So I'll link it at the end of this
in I'll Do More Avatar.
The Last Airbender, Netflix videos
once they do start releasing more footage
that'd be like the next big conversation
we have.
Like if one piece was able to succeed,
will that also be able to succeed
in the same way?
careful for spoilers.
If you haven't seen the one piece
Netflix episodes or read
the original manga,
in essentially the live action episodes
followed the character arcs of the manga
in the animated series pretty closely.
There were a bunch of changes,
but because they did a speedrun over 61
episodes, that was no surprise.
there was a bunch of stuff
they had to skip over
a bunch of characters
they had to remove and stuff
that they rearranged.
really good example of that
is that in the original manga,
the east blue saga
basically ends with the loguetown arc,
they also added all the Garp stuff
at the end of season one with him
confronting Luffy in the straw hats
instead of the other Marines
from the anime,
in the original anime, in the manga,
he didn't really become a huge character
to much later in the story.
So you don't really find out
that he's Luffy's grandfather
until much, much later.
the reason why they probably change this,
also the reason why they probably made
Kobe and Helmut Bo much bigger characters
throughout the Netflix episodes
is because they wanted to focus
on the smaller number of characters
overall through the entire
run of the live action series.
however many seasons they wind up
making it to, assuming they plan
on doing a full saga per season in adapt
the entire run in the manga.
We'll see about that.
But we're talking like a 20 plus year
run of manga
there are a billion one piece characters.
There's
no way they can do all them justice,
so you kind of expect them
to winnow things down
and just focus on a core group
of characters that the entire series,
the way they're cutting characters out
during season one, just expect them
to continue to do that
in future seasons with future arcs.
the ending of the live action
series ends with the hour long part arc,
which is sort of combined in the cut out
a little bit from the loguetown
arc, I'm assuming,
because they pushed some of that
to season two with the smoking man.
and they also combined a little bit
with this last buggy part during loguetown
making him the subordinate of hour long
probably in service of setting buggy up
as a bigger character in the future.
even though he also does become
a much bigger character in future arcs.
they were kind of accurate
to the way that Boogie's character
is portrayed,
at least early on in the story.
Like, the whole idea
is that everybody in the world of one
piece thinks that buggy isn't really
taking advantage of his chop
chop fruit abilities to their full extent,
and if he did
figure out how his powers actually work,
he could become way more powerful.
so I don't think it's a spoiler to say
that eventually he does do that
and does become way more powerful.
They're that ending tag scene
where he meets Alveda
and they seem like
they're going to team up against Lupi.
I think that's part of the idea too,
is that all the villains
that Luffy defeats
that are from the manga,
from the original anime
will slowly team up in the live action
Netflix series against them.
some of you may have recognized
the actor who played Boogie was Jeff Ward.
Most people know him from Marvel's
Agents of Shield.
I thought he did a pretty decent job, even
though they changed a lot of his story.
They did have a lot of moments
that they tried to include
from the manga or copying panels. Exactly.
From magazines there were a lot of changes
to the original story all around.
But when they were trying to be accurate,
they were pretty accurate.
some moments were just meant to carry
the vibe
of the original versions of the scenes,
which is totally different things
going on in them, like the way they did
all the character flashbacks
for their back stories,
the way they swapped around all the extra
bits, introducing the characters.
Like you
see how Zorro wound up in chains way
before they revealed that in the original
anime during episode eight.
They speed run the hour long park Arc
explained how he took over Nami's village
and she spent the rest of her life
up to this point,
trying to earn enough money
to buy it back from him.
The whole story with Nami
pretending to be their friend and joined
the straw hat pirates so she could steal
the map for all long is pretty accurate
to the original story,
as is her ending after Luffy defeats Arlan
and the way he treats her
throughout that whole story.
regardless
of how people feel about the Netflix
live action series in general,
like love it or Hate it,
most people will probably agree that Inaki
did a great job of portraying Lupi.
He's got this heart of gold.
He always stays true to his beliefs.
He always tries to see the best in people.
during the live action ending,
when they learn what Nami has done,
stealing from them and leaving with Arlen,
he immediately believes
something terrible has happened to her
to make her do that.
She's still a good person.
That's right. Out of the original story,
he still believes in her
after she steals from them.
so when they show up to help her
with hour long that's accurate
and her realizing that
they are her friends after all enjoyed
the straw hat pirate's crew for real
the second time.
they cut down their fight
against the hour long pirates
and cut out a few characters.
But they did pretty much the same thing
with pretty much all the major encounters
during the episodes
there are a lot of minor villains,
a lot of secondary characters
that just got cut completely.
Luffy getting his first Wanted poster
after did These Are Long was accurate,
but because it happened
earlier in the manga
he got the wanted poster earlier
in the manga The actual poster is accurate
too, and Usopp is also
in that original poster.
generally they try to be pretty accurate
with the way they did
the actual wanted posters themselves.
probably one of the major changes was garb
Kobe in helmet
though the Marines showing up to test
Luffy right at the end.
Kobe and helmet though did continue
to have adventures with the Marines
in the original storyline, but they were
much bigger, like right at the beginning.
And then you don't really see
too much of them until much later on.
they weren't nearly as big of characters
as the live action episodes made them out
to be during episode eight,
when Garp agrees to train them
to get stronger, that's them basically
adapting The Diary of Kobe in memos.
Serials from the manga
they're part of the short term focused
cover page serials, which were meant to be
supplemental stories throughout the cover
pages of select chapters of the manga,
the live action show
seems like it's just upgrading those
into more of the ongoing episodes.
The Movie versus Garp ending is a change
in that it didn't happen
in the original overlong park arc,
but the vibe of their relationship
and Garp intentions towards
Luffy are true to the manga.
They just wait until a way later
in the original story to clarify that.
basically Garp respects Luffy
for wanting to be his own man,
pursuing his dream
of being the Pirate King,
finding the one piece
sailing the grand line
It's true that originally
when Luthi was much younger,
he did want him to become a marine,
but eventually, once Luthi made it clear
that wasn't going to happen, Garp left him
at the Windmill Village eventually.
Even though we don't really see
that during the live action series,
you just see it
pick up with a younger Luffy
and Shanks when he super punches Luthi.
That's right out of the manga.
He used to do that to Luffy
when he was younger
and get super pissed at him
for breaking the rules.
Right now I'm expecting them to continue
using GARP in a more prominent role
than they did in the manga.
The same way in future seasons.
Like in the manga,
he kind of floats in and out of the story,
so to speak, to make as many pirate puns
as possible.
they didn't really get into
what happened to Luffy's actual father,
but they'll probably clarify
that in future seasons.
They get into that later in the manga
to Speaking of Shanks, though,
there is a moment at the end of the series
where Miho shows up to let him know
what happened to Lupi,
how he achieves his dream
of becoming a pirate, his wanted poster.
But his relationship with Garp
was a little bit different.
He continues to be Zorro's
rival, though, in the original story.
They'll continue to do that
in future seasons
basically the two major levels of power
that you can achieve
before becoming the Pirate king or
the seven warlords or the four emperors.
The difference
between those two organizations,
or just the amount of territory
they control and what their relationship
with the world government in the Marines
are the seven warlords have more
of an agreement with the world government.
They'll work with them sometimes,
like you see me
kind of doing with Garp temporarily.
But the difference with the Four Emperors
is that they're powerful enough
to basically give the world
government the middle finger
and do whatever they want,
which is why you see me
Like, you know what?
I'm not going to do this
and just bails on him
the way they had Shanks lounging around
and me calling him out for being so
lazy, though I think it's a set up
Shanks rise as one of the four emperors.
I think they're trying to say
that during this scene,
Shanks hasn't become one yet and is kind
of wasting his potential in the manga.
He's meant to be
one of the greatest pirates in the world.
they'll probably just show his rise
in future seasons and eventually
what happens when he and Luffy
eventually do meet each other again
after they've both gotten way
more powerful?
His relationship with Lucy,
though, is pretty accurate.
Like he is kind of a father figure to him
more than Luffy's real father,
the ending scene with the barrel is right
out of the manga where they all declare
their dreams and intentions
they want to achieve.
Luffy becoming the king of the Pirates
finding gold.
Roger's one piece Treasure Zoro
becoming the world's best swordsman.
Nami mapping the entire world, Sanji
finding the all blue Usopp
being a brave warrior.
The funny thing too, is when they're
plotting out their next course
and they see Reverse Mountain
and Nami isn't quite sure
what it actually means.
Like, wait a minute,
this mountain seems like it goes up.
Like to
we actually go up a mountain
to get to the grand line
and go on our next part of our journey
that is right out of the manga
and right out of the anime.
The river.
They take really does
go up the mountain like you go up
a mountain to get to the other side.
they'll probably cover that
at the very beginning of season two.
the whole post-credits scene
stinger of the smoking man
looking at luffy's wanted poster
implying he's going after him
is smoker from the manga or captain
or however you want to think of them.
He's another marine captain
that they introduced
much earlier in the original story
it looks like
they just saved him for season two.
Originally he debut during the loguetown
Arc and was a big villain during that.
But they completely cut him out
during season one.
like a lot of the characters.
He becomes a much bigger antagonist
over the seasons,
but a lot of times he does work with movie
and then they go back to being villains
to each other after they've defeated
some bigger threat together.
I'll do a much larger
one piece Netflix season two video later
this weekend
to talk about the Arab Boston saga
which is like the next big saga
in the manga and talk more
about what they're actually going
to do during season two
because they will be doing
the same basic thing
they did during season one,
like kind of a speed run
version of the Arab Boston saga.
Netflix seems pretty confident
that they will renew the series.
We'll see about that.
Usually
they wait a while to announce that, but
because we're in the middle of the strikes
right now,
they might wait till after the strikes
before they start working on that
and make a formal announcement Overall,
I feel like they had some good moments.
I would say they did
a good job of capturing the spirit
and the weirdness of the original story.
A lot of people that are brand
new to one piece
probably won't realize that, you know,
it is a super weird series.
It is amazing.
They even tried to adapt it.
it's going to be one of those series
where you either love it or you hate it.
Like when it was good, it was solid,
but when it was bad, it was kind of bad
Overall, though,
I would call it a big success for them.
Like it could have gone way, way worse.
and it does make me hopeful
for their live action Avatar,
The Last Airbender Netflix series.
Overall, I would call this
a good benchmark for that.
I would expect the same thing from Avatar,
The Last Airbender one that premieres
next year, I'll do another video for that
when they release the next big Avatar,
The Last Airbender trailer.
It won't air until next year.
Like I said,
but I will be doing videos for it.
Let me know in the comments.
What did you think of the Netflix
one piece series
and what do you want them to do
during season two if they're going
to make some more changes?
Everyone click here for that
first big Avatar, The Last Airbender
Netflix trailer and click here
for my Ahsoka Episode 4 video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!